I have something for you today, which you
might say is almost sad.
In a way, this might be the saddest, most
pathetic, most embarrassing interview that
Fox News host David Asman has ever done.
And I've been watching David Asman on and
off for decades.
At this point, the interview I'm going to
play for you has the feel and the vibe of
the North Korean state media broadcasts from
how biased and sycophantic it is to the Dear
Leader, which in David Admin's case is Donald
Trump.
Fox decided to interview Georgia Republican
Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger, who
is a vile voter suppressing pro Trump Republican
who has become an enemy of Trump because he
has said, listen, I can't just steal the election
for you.
And that was even too far for Brian Kemp and
Brad Raffensperger.
So David Asman brings on Brad Raffensperger
and frames up a question for him that seems
like a North Korean state media question,
framing up a question about how it really
doesn't seem like Biden even could have won
because Biden was in the basement and Operation
Warp Speed was so great.
This is a reporter from the supposed news
side of FOX News.
Listen to the frame up on this question.
Folks outside of Georgia and outside of other
the highly contested states saying, look at
these numbers.
Joe Biden got 12 million more votes than Barack
Obama on Barack Obama's best election.
I mean, how is that possible?
He spent the whole the whole campaign bunker
down in his basement, not saying much at all.
The president has had enormous successes with
the economy, with operation warp speed, et
cetera.
How could he have done 12 million more votes
than Barack Obama?
That's that's really the overall writing question
in most people's minds.
Again, the people who are out of the weeds,
unlike yourself, you can understand those
questions, right?
Well, I do just imagine that Assman claims,
you know, most people, people who aren't in
the weeds, most people are thinking, I don't
know.
I mean, Biden was in the basement.
Trump won with Operation Warp Speed and he
won with the economy.
And Biden gets 12 million more votes than
Obama must be fraud.
That's the average person that Assman is pretending
exists.
Now, those people do exist, there's no doubt,
but it's about half of Trump voters.
It's not most people in the United States.
Here is Brad Raffensperger, to his credit,
saying that this is the truth.
Joe Biden got more votes and some people can't
handle it.
Biden did win.
And people can't handle the truth sometimes
because they're very disappointed.
And the results I get that I voted for President
Trump also.
But the end of the day, we did everything
that we could.
We did an audit of the race.
President Trump still lost.
Then we did a full recount.
Then we audited the absentee ballot signatures
on the envelopes and Cobb County and we found
only two votes out of fifteen thousand that
we went ahead and surveyed along with you
by only two out of fifteen thousand that weren't
done correctly.
And they were actually the spouses have filled
out those applications for their spouses,
are signed the signatures.
And so we have a safe, secure process.
And people have to realize that you need to
go out and vote and that's how you win elections.
Getting out and voting is how you win.
Which brings up a real question about whether
telling Georgia Republicans that the elections
there are rigged is a good way to get out
the vote.
And by the way, notice that in his answer,
Brad Raffensperger does basically agree with
the premise of the question from David Asman.
But he says the numbers just weren't there.
Raffensperger says, you know.
Doesn't really make sense.
I mean, Biden was in his basement, Trump did
great with Operation Warp Speed, I supported
Trump, but we just couldn't find the votes.
Not enough people turned out.
So even in his answer, they're still conceding
a bunch of the framing of the question by
David Asman.
So there you have it.
And this is we there's I mentioned this earlier
one upmanship battle.
I expect that once Trump finally leaves office,
we are going to see OCN and Newsmax by virtue
of their wild reporting, push or drag some
aspects of Fox News to become even more radicalized
to maintain an audience.
That's my expectation.
We'll see if it comes true.